when I was waving it it went in and then
it went like that and I was like oh my
God what happened that's your defense
all over he fell over on me six times he
kept falling and bouncing around the
night the earthquake you know I was like
what's going on
[Music]
so you guys listen to drill rap at all
what is that did you say drill wrap
is it the African one or like UK yeah
yeah that's tough I think it's kind of
tight one plus one is two two plus two
is four man's not hot that's a parody
yeah yeah
uh how could I be homophobic my
girlfriends get like is that was that
kid it's okay it says that you know
y'all know what's up y'all know what's
up y'all know what's up is that like
like stormzy and all them who's that
like Berna and the whole crew I like
this yeah you're uh UK rap stuff yeah UK
rap stuff I think it's tied so um here's
an example it um this dude uploaded a
drill rap song that was talking [__]
about some other dudes uh gang and uh
the dude that uploaded it was 16. and
then the other dude he was talking [__]
on was 19. oh that dude catches him like
going on the bus and he stabs him to
death over oh bro is that Tupac and
Biggie [__] huh not quite a little bit
but uh but it's 16 and 19. yeah so are
they like the kids on the comments that
are like yo just give me a chance I'm
like the newest rapper like come to my
channel pull up yeah just pull up dude
yeah but not really I mean they a lot of
drill rap does have some pretty explicit
Like lyrics in case you guys don't know
a lot of it's um not all of it's
supposed to be true by the way so it
could have a lot of really [__] up
things in it but you know they don't
they're not always being 100 authentic
it's really for the music too there's a
lot of Raps like that bro right but then
for the cloud but that's called Studio
gangsters also I'm not sure if they just
say that also because they don't want to
be
um caught from any crimes that are no
you can't anymore I think it's Jay-Z and
whoever uh pushed on that law that said
that nobody can be like uh indicted for
the lyricism anymore but that's how they
got Young Thug and goodness it's a
little bit after yeah but but now after
they just change that loss that log kind
of doesn't work because it's it's not
that you just can't present that as the
evidence but you can use it to go find
other evidence
you know what I mean like probable cause
like if you rap about like you killed
somebody over here I could just go look
and if I find what I thought would be
there I could use that but I can't say
oh your honor he said he did it it was 2
30 in the morning it was dark and bubble
and then you're like oh [__] okay so if
I pull the CCTV camera at two thirds
exactly yeah exactly exactly yeah you
could just you could just skirt around
it use it as your map but you can't it
can't be the meat you can't go oh see he
did it he said it right here how dumb
would you be to just be honest like kill
this guy ran away I'm staying at Motel
Eight um
drill rap got I was gonna say I buried
his body at the Central Park right by
the pond
they're like they dig it right there and
they're like oh there there are bones
here yeah they're like hard the one
thing that's kind of like dumb about
this is that uh so the dude finds the
guy and he's chasing him around with his
knife and then he's literally it says he
stabs him like one time but like all the
way through is like chest oh no on the
side so the dude dies but the defense of
this guy when he's in court is like no I
was what I was doing was I was trying to
scare him away by waving the knife in
front of him and then it got when I was
waving it it went in and then it went
like that and I was like oh my God what
happened I know it's almost like that's
your defense over he fell over on me six
times stop
you kept falling and bouncing around the
night the earthquake you know like
what's going on no no no I was just
trying to scare him I think he's getting
like 25 years damn oh dear goodness yeah
but it's like crazy because the Dude the
what the original lyrical content was
was like he was rapping about how
basically a guy from the other gang had
got stabbed to death and he was rapping
about how he was happy about it so then
this dude from that gang came and found
him and yeah and stabbed him to death
but he was so young that's the thing
that's kind of art though you know what
I mean if I want to take the emotion the
immorality aside I'm kind of like whoa
hip hop you can't Nana Nana someone
though you can't what you can't no no no
someone you know
yeah
someone then retaliation is a coming oh
I see what you mean no no I'm talking
about
hey bro
no you can't Nana Nana you can't do that
yeah did you if you do that like dude no
matter what you do people are gonna come
after you like you don't even have to be
gangster right and then if you do that
like in a political level or like
anything else yeah you're you're asking
for like a slap back that's true banana
is kind of a you can't do that to get
away with you can't ha ha either you
can't do that yeah you can't be like
pull up it's like well [__] okay have
you seen those videos of dudes on live
and they're like pull up I'm at this
address and someone pulls up yeah and
shoots them and [__] Bro those live like
when they're on live on Facebook live
whatever they're shooting I'm like bro
what the [__] is that's just wild yeah
yeah that's so wild it's super wild but
that's what's kind of crazy about I
guess with drill rap it gets a it's
getting like kind of a closer look
because a lot of the [__] they say
they're gonna do sometimes it actually
happens at a higher rate than any other
so if they hear it someone can be
smiling Stokes the fire steps ahead like
chess and they're like oh
yeah and that's kind of why you know
academics he was getting a lot of [__]
for it because he was one of the first
people to really put a big Spotlight on
drill rap and because he did that these
dudes that are rapping against other
people started to get more attention and
now it put more weight on the claims
that they were making in these songs so
if it's like I hate you and I'm rapping
and I'm talking [__] on nice going
academics yeah he got like a there's a
pretty in-depth uh almost like a mini
doc about did you really expose them
like did you give them good exposure or
did you give him bad exposure because in
a way like now they have to come through
with what they're like saying so if I
was Sherlock Holmes then I think the
best thing I would be doing in the UK is
listening to all the music and writing
notes about the next crimes they're
gonna be doing
Sherlock's constantly like just a
thriller Elementary my dear Watson
yeah that's what sucks is that a lot of
good lives are kind of getting lost over
this because this beef is getting
heavier than it should be in a way I
feel like this has been going on since
like our generation and everything it's
like it just keeps going like listening
comment on the way here and I'm like
what like what is music today like how
is that even okay though like how is
that even you talking about old common
stuff or new common stuff like
what like 2004 comments like go
okay
yeah we have music light turned green
you know saying go lights red let's go
oh no
we were in high school music was violent
bro yeah but the but the murder rate
between rappers today is worse than it
was back then yeah whoa we started it I
mean think about it we launched Tupac
and Biggie right people will go oh two
bucket biggie but it's like these guys
even get a chance to get to Tupac and
piggy they died at their first album
like that's kind of [__] that's true
like highly talented musicians you know
they didn't get to live yeah because
back then it'd be like yo did you hear
me he was talking trash on you on his
[__] mixtapes what did you get that
mixtape it was on this corner right here
you got to get that forward you know
nowadays like everything's everywhere
it's like it's like I tagged you in this
[__] pull up you're like whoa and these
are just the people that we that got
famous enough for you to know they died
that's true like there's still local
people like like SoundCloud rappers are
killing each other yeah yeah like the
Chicago rappers
yeah well he just got like straight
jacked wasn't that the um was it the
roscos
Bros tweeted the location
like just last month it was uh this
rapper who went to Roscoe literally had
an interview that came out a week before
two weeks before like talking about how
he was telling his girlfriend to stop
putting their location and this one time
she did put the location at Roscoe's and
someone just she stood like Instagram
Story how come girls don't listen they
murdered him she posted that Roscoe's
like chicken and waffles like we all do
but she had like the diamond ring or
whatever and they like had expensive
[__] and something just pulled up and
there's a video of him like just lying
on the floor like it's just like what we
see today is wild it's wild like I can't
unsee that and that's another artist
that's like he was on his way man like
he was killing it and then like to get
cut short like that over some [__]
man that's why they're kind of getting
on you know they kind of got into
academics a little bit because they were
like even though you want to Spotlight
this community more you're hurting
because that's not fair though right to
put that on academics like well it
depends that you look because it's like
any growing Community goes to Growing
Pains right there's always like a wild
wild west for anything until something
like it eventually has to change in
order for it to like truly survive or
die off like that's just kind of how any
culture is right so I mean
there's no such thing as bad press
[Laughter]
is that you want to be quoted hot Tech
dude I don't know
oh that's the same like
like that by inflating into that they
said there's less crime today but the
thing is it makes it feel like crazier
because we can see it all now yeah they
always be saying there's less crime
every time there's more crime I hate
that yeah I feel it because all the
places that I used to get scared of
going I don't feel that anymore yeah but
we also get smart about where we go and
we yeah
Chinatown the other day to get some
pork belly and Duck and I remember
walking around remembering there used to
be Chinese gangs out here that would
pull up and like
talk to me in a mean way and I had to
miss somebody I used to risk my life to
get some duck but now that doesn't get a
duck to get a duck I imagine though Joe
pulls up now everybody else is all
scared I think [__] is just different
like remember I was saying like we were
always talking about how like dude
that's dope that nowadays you don't feel
like Asian gangs are a threat as much
like they exist but they're not out
there like harassing everybody but then
I was talking to this teenager dude that
lives in sgv still and he said it was
still bad but that's because we don't
we're just not there the same way I see
them but then they Giggle and go can I
get a picture so maybe that's why it's
different probably yeah
it's different just the other day me and
Bart went to go eat hot pot and then
there were these like
two from head to toe Asian guys that
came in they said they started giggling
and they're like your Asian mom
I remember you're basically a made man
in that community so I'm not gonna touch
you but then maybe that's why I feel I
don't feel threatened anymore yeah I
think we're just not the prime targets
anymore before I used to go in there and
I'm like eating food and I'm like oh my
God but like when's the last time you
went to an Asian pool hall you know like
I didn't even know those still exist
exactly but we don't do [__] like that
anymore so we're like running into
that's less you're right
I just think the world is safer because
I want to think it's safe I'm richer now
and I'm away from the hood
[Music]